let's start by looking at cases of
covid-19 across the UK these dots here
represent different days worth of
figures that we've had in recent weeks
and you can see that black line is
showing you the seven day average very
high of us at the start of the Year very
low and then it's kind of come up to
pretty high levels at the moment as for
where it's heading well it's slightly
unclear it's down a bit over the last
week or so but it's still early days
because you don't really know for sure
what the return to schools is actually
going to do it's still quite early may
need another couple of weeks to
understand that but what we do know is
that when you break that down by age
group which I've done here all of these
are different types of age group well
look at the age groups that are where
it's growing the fastest in terms of
amount of covert 19. 15 to 19 worlds 10
to 14 year olds So within that group
obviously that have now been decided
that they will get those vaccinations
will be offered those vaccinations The
Hope obviously is that those lines will
be reduced by that because we do know
that the vaccines somewhat reduce
transmission we know they're very good
actually even better at reducing the
impact of the disease so reducing your
risk of going to hospital or indeed
dying and that's what we have here these
show you covert death rates by
vaccination status and so the higher
they are the more people are dying it's
age-adjusted and what you can see here
is around that spring period just look
how much it was unvaccinated people
obviously fewer people who are
vaccinated then but it was unvaccinated
people primarily who were dying and
those with vaccines which are the other
lines here either having one dose or
indeed both doses have much lower death
rates what I'll do is I'll just zoom in
on that area over on the far right hand
side so these are more recent months and
although they are all a lot lower so
we're zooming in fully vaccinated really
really low uh indeed fully vaccinated
and then you've got unvaccinated and one
dose higher so just underlining how
important getting two doses is to reduce
that risk of mortality as is and here's
another way of looking at it just
breaking the Whole Thing Down by age and
looking at the likelihood of cases
turning in to death so the higher these
bars are the higher the percentage of
someone who contracts covid-19 then
going on on to die and it's just done by
age so you can see from the oldest
through to the youngest there there's 80
plus over there what I'll do those bars
Show you people who have been vaccinated
fully vaccinated had two doses now we'll
look at those who haven't been
vaccinated at all so no jobs whatsoever
and look how much higher those red bars
unvaccinated people are than the blue
bars all the way through and just to
underline it look at 70 uh to 79 year
olds uh 14.2 percent of unvaccinated
cases went on to die compared with those
who are vaccinated 1.9 just look at the
difference there it really is Stark but
the further you get down the age
Spectrum the less Stark it is you can
probably not even see that there are
bars there but there are but they're
very low indeed as you get down to these
kind of 18 to 29 and under 18 groups and
in fact with under 18s when it comes to
unvaccinated people you're talking about
naught Point naught naught two percent
uh who go on sadly to die that
underlines it you know it's not
mortality it's not the only reason why
these vaccination decisions are taken
but it's part of the reason why this was
such a difficult decision